- You're all sisters.
Well, tell me about you guys
and then I'll rap about that.
What'd you guys do?
- Oh, can we just not go there?
(woman laughs)
- I have a dog name Professor, that's fun.
- Hannah, Emery and Claire,
dog named Professor,
but wait, so why don't
you want to go there?
- I mean its just like, you know,
you just will pin me as a certain person.
- No I won't.
- Okay, fine.
I'm an eCommerce consultant.
- Oh yeah, okay, no, that's fine.
(all laughing)
I don't know what that means.
- I go to school in Arkansas.
- I like fanny packs.
- I'll stand further away and mask down.
(group chattering)
Okay.
Okay, Hannah, Emery, Claire.
You've already had it?
- Yes sir.
- My gosh, let's do this.
(hip hop music)
♪ Three sisters with the blonde hair. ♪
♪ She's already had the
COVID, named Claire. ♪
♪ And then we go to
this side, yeah, sure, ♪
♪ With Hannah and the
nice pooch, Professor, ♪
♪ Like X from X-Men, ♪
♪ I'm checkin', see it
there in the wheelchair ♪
♪ Call it professor Xavier. ♪
♪ I'm assuming your dog's
got the use of it's legs, ♪
♪ And what's going on in Emery's head. ♪
♪ She's like, what's the
purpose to be on this earth. ♪
♪ I'm consulting in eCommerce, ♪
♪ And helping people when they
got their little business ♪
♪ And puttin' out their emails in press. ♪
♪ Everything, buy it
each, that they saw. ♪
♪ And then we got you in
Arkansas, In Fayetteville ♪
♪ Yeah I don't know a lot. ♪
♪ Once a time ago I visit Little Rock. ♪
♪ It was real shit,
what a horrible city. ♪
♪ If you livin' there now,
your city is shitty, ♪
♪ I don't like it, but
that's okay I miss there. ♪
♪ We did a trio with the sisters, ♪
♪ You like fanny packs. ♪
♪ And let me say my minds on that ♪
♪ In my country, we don't
call it, called a bum bag. ♪
♪ That's a true fact, ♪
♪ Because a fanny is your bum. ♪
♪ And now more words from
the four, give more. ♪
♪ Call it ass, A double S
shake it like your twerkin' ♪
♪ I like checkin' out the asses
go berserk in a strip club. ♪
♪ I make the thing clap ♪
♪ Like The Motherload, yeah ♪
And then the rap, what did you say?
♪ Corgi, It's kinda odd ♪
♪ They hear the accent,
say that's a British dog ♪
♪ Owned by the queen, keep in her home. ♪
♪ Buckingham palace, they're
always shitting on the throne. ♪
♪ Bowin' down, with their
brown and the white fur. ♪
♪ I need more words,
give it right there, ♪
♪ Throw it in, yeah, you
said it like you asked ♪
♪ Water from the man
with the nice mustache. ♪
♪ It's real nice. ♪
♪ Yeah, I might befriend
you; (but) in the past, ♪
♪ Mustache meant you're a sex
offender, but that's okay ♪
♪ Flow like water off a duck's back. ♪
♪ That's the water, the
H2O, I knock back. ♪
♪ What we got? One more, here we go. ♪
♪ Stand on one leg when
I rap like Flamingo. ♪
♪ Like a pink thing ♪
♪ Eatin' all the krill. ♪
♪ See 'em in the zoo, turn
gray when they're ill, ♪
♪ That's a true fact ♪
♪ Need to get the color in the feather. ♪
♪ There we go, we drop a
rap from a British fella. ♪
♪ I hope you enjoyed it
bringin' y'all together. ♪
♪ With the rhymes that
we did that are clever, ♪
♪ That's it. ♪
(all cheering)
- I hope you're enjoying the video.
Make sure you hit that like button
and I will release another
episode of me rapping
in Crested Butte.
- A kid, cuttin' his
thumb off on a table saw.
- Yeah, some family counseling.
- So a kid cutting his
thumb off in a wood shop
and traumatic family counseling.
(both laughing)
Okay.
It's gonna be a nice and easy one,
I'm gonna drop a beat.
- [Woman] Make this explicit.
- Explicit. Just really horrible.
♪ Make this explicit, ♪
♪ I' betta make it good, ♪
♪ I'm slippin' on the table saw. ♪
♪ And then I'm gushing blood ♪
♪ Like a geyser, like Old Faithful ♪
♪ In Yellowstone. ♪
♪ I gotta call the parents, ♪
♪ I gotta get him home. ♪
♪ He's yelling out like, "please, sir ♪
♪ I used to have a thumb
right there see there, ♪
♪ But now there's nothin'." ♪
♪ All the pain, it lingers in the shop, ♪
♪ Near the wood tools, now four fingers. ♪
♪ What's he gonna do? ♪
♪ No hitchhikin' ♪
♪ He's got no thumb, ♪
♪ All the cars drive by him ♪
♪ They're like, fuck the guy. ♪
♪ I saw him before, ♪
♪ Leave him on the hard shoulder ♪
♪ And saw slice right through, ♪
♪ Leave him on his own, ♪
♪ Bleedin' out upon the floor. ♪
♪ Emitting up all the bone
and the flesh and the skin. ♪
♪ I don't wanna make you faint, ♪
♪ But let me say it's my favorite place. ♪
♪ I'm no slouch when I'm there ♪
♪ On the therapist couch,
marriage, counselin' ♪
♪ Yeah, you know what I allow. ♪
♪ Got the lady with the ring ♪
♪ And she throws it on the floor ♪
♪ And says, "I caught
my husband with the ♪
♪ neighborhood whore. ♪
♪ No more, ♪
♪ I'm callin' a divorce. ♪
♪ The husband's like, "no,
I deny it, of course." ♪
♪ I'm not saying this is what happens ♪
♪ Every session, but
just think, way back, ♪
♪ They were poppin' the question. ♪
♪ But now, they totally ♪
♪ Kinda broke down. ♪
♪ Cause he's gone around
every hoe in town, ♪
♪ It's like, no, please
I'll vouch for him. ♪
♪ You try to fix this shit
with the counselin'. ♪
♪ And what do your offer? ♪
♪ What do you say? ♪
♪ Maybe you could dress up
and do some role play. ♪
♪ That's actually a quick fix. ♪
♪ Everybody know, there we go counselin' ♪
♪ And the wood shop, bro. ♪
(all cheering)
- A Shih Tzu.
- A Shih Tzu, okay, cool, so,
COVID quarantine, bikes,
Crested Butte, and a Shih Tzu.
This is a freestyle, like I
said, made up on the spot.
I love your Louis Vuitton
sneakers by the way,
Are they real? Are you very wealthy?
- Well they're Vans.
Oh, they're Vans, okay great, I like it.
Nice.
(hip hop music)
♪ Not real LV, It's a screen- ♪
♪ -print on the Vans when
you're in quarantine. ♪
♪ You're like, "aw shit,
I wish that I did ♪
♪ All of the live events before COVID- ♪
♪ 19, came up from the East," ♪
♪ Lockdown, two weeks at least. ♪
♪ If you've been in contact
with infected people, ♪
♪ But I stay inside, yeah, ♪
♪ Never be a sequel. ♪
♪ Technically, it's gonna spike again, ♪
♪ When you're on the
mountain with your friends. ♪
♪ You wanna have fun ♪
♪ How you even gonna do it? ♪
♪ No wheels on the bike, yeah ♪
♪ How you pursue it? ♪
♪ Just one like a unicycle, ♪
♪ It's vital. ♪
♪ Hands in the air when you walk
past the side, though, yeah ♪
♪ But in orange with a beanie. ♪
♪ Don't go no mask on, don't be these. ♪
♪ That's okay, bike with a seat. ♪
♪ When you got the shock absorbers, ♪
♪ You need those. ♪
♪ Hatin' all the things
that I want to see. ♪
♪ There just checkin' his phone, ♪
♪ Like Justin Bieber. ♪
♪ I like that. ♪
♪ Lookin' so smooth, ♪
♪ Diamonds in the ear, ♪
♪ He's a Crested Butte. ♪
♪ Dude, do you live here, ♪
♪ Maybe just a tourist, a great sound ♪
♪ In the shadow of a mountain. ♪
♪ I adore this. ♪
♪ Look at the crepuscular rays. ♪
♪ I need a little dog from
the shelter to save. ♪
♪ Walk in' and there, ♪
♪ I pick you, like a Pokemon, ♪
♪ It's a cute Shih Tzu. ♪
♪ Pick it up, ♪
♪ It's a dog that's small. ♪
♪ Neuter the dog so it
ain't got no balls. ♪
♪ Not a bitch, it's a man,
so we can't have the puppy. ♪
♪ I'm lovin' the Shih
Tzu, yeah, had a looky. ♪
♪ If you only got a lion and a rhino, ♪
♪ That's a shit zoo, ♪
♪ Get the joke, bro? ♪
♪ Like that, anyway we flow. ♪
♪ For you guys, yeah ♪
♪ Three guys and one girl. ♪
♪ Was gonna say bro, but it don't make sense ♪
♪ I like that your hands in
your pockets, so tense. ♪
♪ Like you're feelin' ♪
♪ Slightly underwhelmed. ♪
♪ But there you go, ♪
♪ That's a rap that I tell. ♪
There you go.
- Hell yeah, man, hell yeah.
(boys clapping)
That was good as hell.
- Haemorrhoids.
(all laughing)
- Proctologist, haemorrhoids,
a cute kitten, and a bus stop.
Okay.
Imma drop a little beat for you guys,
this is a free style, all
made up about those things.
So, let's do it.
(hip hop music)
♪ I'm feelin' in love, ♪
♪ I'm feelin' smitten. ♪
♪ Got a cute little cat ♪
♪ Like I'm pickin' a kitten. ♪
♪ It's got the whiskers. ♪
♪ A risk there, I survive, ♪
♪ Like a cat, you know I got nine lives. ♪
♪ If you cough on me, ♪
♪ I still pull right through. ♪
♪ I need a bit of cream, ♪
♪ What does this do? ♪
♪ Preparation H, it's helps me soothe. ♪
♪ I apply it to my backside,
reading the tube. ♪
♪ It's not lube. ♪
♪ It's like a numbing thing, ♪
♪ Like an ointment. ♪
♪ Put it on the finger, ♪
♪ The ring, remove it. ♪
♪ If you're at the doctor,
then follow this, ♪
♪ He's says "Chris, bend over",
Proctologist ♪
♪ Is the specialty that I study ♪
♪ I'm not a doctor, I'm just a busy body ♪
♪ Who likes to walk around ♪
♪ And insert my phalanges ♪
♪ Most obvious things
from the man, please. ♪
♪ A bus stop, ♪
♪ It says it on the wall. ♪
♪ Get imagination, the brain, too small. ♪
♪ But that's okay, ♪
♪ That's the thing on offer. ♪
♪ Are you here at the stop
off to see the doctor? ♪
♪ Visit over there, ♪
♪ Hard to avoid. ♪
♪ Check the prostate, ♪
♪ Check the haemorrhoids, ♪
♪ And here's my advice from me to you, ♪
♪ If you don't want haemorrhoids, ♪
♪ Don't spend too long on the loo. ♪
There you go.
(all laughing)
Thank you for watching guys,
make sure you like, comment, subscribe,
and I will see you next
time for another episode
of me rapping in Crested Butte.